and you never got into any scandal with
sex videos or anything like that you
avoided all that [__] not yet not yet
but it's just there's still time
[Music]
you talk about weird stories so you're a
young girl it becomes apparent that
you're very good looking and your
friends
did a trick on you yeah well Frenemies
right you're in uh what was it was this
in high school would you say how old
were you at this point 16 16. I could
drive yes uh you get a call from a local
department store they say hey Cindy
you're a beautiful girl we'd love for
you to come to the department store and
model and and uh this is a great break
for a girl where were you living you
were living in Illinois in Illinois and
it's exciting that's how you get into
the modeling business out of nowhere so
I was like wow like someone must have
noticed me walking down Main Street you
know and you probably went to your
parents and said hey I'm going down to
the local department store they've asked
me to model and you're excited and your
hopes and dreams are coming true and you
get to the store in the store I guess
you walk into the store and you see this
from here to model and they look at you
like you're crazy
and it turned out your friends pulled a
prank on you your so-called friends
pulled a prank on you they called your
house pretended to be the department
store that had a hurt oh I literally I
can still remember that feeling of just
my
I mean first of all I ran out of that
store as quick as I could because I just
was mortified and then I saw these two
girls like half a block away standing on
the corners laughing
and it was it was so mean it did hurt it
hurt a lot but
later
I've been able to tap into that you know
like huh I guess I showed them you know
well you said every time you went on a
modeling job and the bigger the modeling
jobs got you think of those two girls
doing that prank what is that does that
relax you in a way or does it say [__]
you I'm gonna be the greatest model I'm
going to make the most money out of
anything it does yeah and I saw them at
my tenure High School reunion too do
they and do they walk up and and uh you
know and suck up to you incredibly
because you're now the famous Cindy
Crawford
they just know to stay away
it's like what did they say success is
the greatest Revenge right I don't have
to say anything
you know I think about your life and you
were married at an early age to a guy
Jill's Ben Simone he's a famous fashion
photographer and The Story Goes that uh
you didn't speak a word of French but in
six months you learned French fluently
you're very much in love yeah are you a
genius you tested in the top percentile
of essay whatever the equivalent of this
is in the top three percent of the
country in my final studies and I went
to you know I I applied to University to
study law that's what I wanted to do
like my stepfather was a lawyer why
didn't you go into law because you were
so beautiful no not at all I took a gap
year because I was young you know I
finished school I was 16 and nine months
and I was going to go and study law at
17. how do you finish school at 16. how
does that happen stayed in nine months
that was just that's the way the system
is in Australia I see so you took the
SAT I said I took my final exams I did
quite well because I studied hard not
because I'm particularly bright right
um and I you know I got into University
and then I took a gap year and and then
during that Gap year I started modeling
how old were you then 16 17. did your
mother did she become a model then I
mean most people somehow no it wasn't
discovered a friend of mine A girlfriend
of mine said to me I've started this
modeling thing you can earn quite a lot
of money I thought I like the idea of
that
she said I bet you 20 bucks if you go to
my modeling agency they'll take you on I
thought even if I lose I win 20 bucks 20
bucks was a lot of time and that a lot
of money at that age for me and it was
at least three hours work at the
pharmacy I was working at right and so I
went along to this modeling agency and
uh and they took me on and then I
started working you were always known as
the body right that was your thing the
body no actually and to tell you the
truth with that was that when time
coined the body I thought to myself hey
very smart how can I capitalize on this
right and that's when I started to build
a brand around body products the body
Consciousness body Wellness
and so it's not a really a an ego place
like oh wow look at me don't I have a
great body it was more a business
decision that I made in 1986.
well you look good thank you yeah you
look I could see why you modeled
professionally made a fortune how old
were you when you started modeling you
started I was 15 years old yeah 15.
where where did you grow up LA and when
you're in La your mother just looked at
you and knew right away you were that
good looking and said I'm going to put
you in modeling my mother looked at me
and had no idea that I was a model my
mom was a medical photographer and
part-time she would take pictures of
women that wanted to model right and I
would hold the bounce card and and and
check her lighting for her as her little
12 year old assistant so how do you get
into modeling if a girl came up to me on
the first day of school and was like you
look like a model and I was like what
she was the first person to ever tell me
that how does one go about becoming a
model I don't understand how you make
that jump well I waited she discovered
me when I was 13. I waited until the
11th grade when I was 15. and I went to
a bunch of agencies and you walked
around with a a picture of yourself I
walked around with some snapshots that
my mom took of me so you must have known
you were good looking and boys must have
started paying attention boy still we're
not paying attention you have to
understand that model does not
necessarily mean beautiful alluring or
beautiful boy when I was younger I was
more of a high fashion model look so it
was a little more quirky and more odd
more interesting and being a black woman
I remember when you started modeling it
was not really that common for a black
woman to be a model and maybe there's
only one black model that's allowed to
be successful exactly I walked into the
agencies and a lot of them were like oh
we only have I'm sorry we already have a
a black model sorry so it's almost
impossible so if someone would have said
to you that you would have made a
fortune as a model you would have left
because at that time it would have been
questionable whether you could even get
work yeah I would have laughed so you
walk in I walk in to the one that said
yes who is that La models and are you
grateful to them because they didn't say
we have already one black model I'm
super grateful I'm probably sitting in
front of you now because of them
although they did tell me I wasn't
photogenic but that and that I should do
runway so I started off with Runway with
them how do you learn how to do that
that walk on the runway what is that all
about studied I studied I studied I
studied and I've seen documentaries and
stuff on you and how you study eat and
like really you studied what the women
did I studied I went to the fashion
library in Los Angeles and like was
obsessed with tape and I'd watch tape of
girls from the 80s and like and just
really like study them 70s too there is
something to study about why some people
break out and some don't yes so what was
the secret that you somehow are more
interesting I think the secret for me
was a lot of research so like when I
went to Paris for the very first time
instead of going to college I went to
Paris I got accepted at every College I
applied to I wanted to you were a good
student writer yes I wanted to be a
writer and a producer for film and
television you didn't go to college no I
didn't I got accepted to all of them but
I got discovered to go to Paris at the
last two weeks before my first day of
college I got discovered and you said
screw College I can make a fortune doing
this model no I said oh my God this is
the craziest decision of my life what am
I going to do I don't know what to do I
talked to my mom my mom said follow your
heart I support you and whatever what
could a girl make uh walking the runways
of Europe can she make how much can you
make it day doing that well back in my
day
um
somewhat some of the top girls are
making ten thousand dollars a fashion
show wow and so you do five a day you do
about 25 per per City So Adam Milan
Paris New York and then maybe a little
bit of London you can pull in 50 G's a
day yeah oh my God you must have been
going berserk yeah I was doing pretty
well
to me this is one of the coolest things
I've ever read so here you are that the
you know the height of the the scene and
you befriend a fellow model Patty Hansen
who is dating Keith Richards and so you
say this sounds so exciting to me
because to me Keith Richards is one of
the greatest the coolest ever like the
coolest guy right not only cool than
than you really even know and so you're
hanging out with the stones and Keith
Richard you describe a scene where
you're on an airplane and Keith is
turning to you and saying hey I just
wrote a song tell me what you think of
it you must have been hearing songs like
you know Ruby Tuesday or Sympathy for
the Devil because he was coming up with
riffs left and right at that point right
it was amazing actually we were on the
Concord together and then when we got in
the limousine gives me the chills yeah
he he put on you know before it was like
up top there or whatever it is and you
know I'm listening and he's going you
know you got ears you know listen to
this and that and other it was just so
cool and he was so any he is so talented
and such a great writer and everything
and just to see them in love and I
remember Patty you know we went down to
the bathroom afterwards and she says
Beverly this is the one I'm like what do
you mean this is the one we're just
hanging out with the guy she said no I'm
going to get married I'm going to have
children with him I'm like whoa whoa
let's slow down honey we're losing
oxygen we're having fun here but don't
you know but and they were and they were
and they did and it's wonderful Beverly
isn't it the most intoxicating to be
hanging out with a rock so who's sitting
there creating some of the world's
greatest music I cannot tell you it was
it great stuff like were you listening
and were you in a way it's the greatest
seduction for for a man to seduce a
woman isn't it well I I you know I've
been around it because remember you know
one of the husbands uh got reggae music
to America and so I was around Bob
Marley and everything and I've kind of
been around a lot of musicians and all
of that and so I was Marley like
unbelievable what is unbelievable
unbelievable well first of all he was so
handsome good-looking dude and just very
oh my God now that's one I regret not
well anyway
why didn't you sleep with people I don't
know what were you doing just too much
for me it was just he he blew your mind
yeah he really did and just you know his
energy and what he was talking about in
his songwriting and you know and all of
that and the pot thing was so much of
his culture like was he constantly
stoned and smoking and did he have the
best weed yeah
he's just the coolest of the cool you
know and these guys can have anything
they want anything they want and you're
probably aware of that too in a way it's
a game too you're like you know what I'm
just not going to give it up so easy for
some of these guys because they can have
anybody and they're you know they're
just going to go on to the next one and
the next one and the next one you know
you know I just like to appreciate them
for you know what they are who what they
have to offer you know it's not really
like a relationship thing for me I can't
get off this plane with Keith Richards
so when he's sitting there do you do you
remember any one song where he turned to
you and said hey what do you think of
this riff and then it was like you know
I don't know satisfaction or something
do you remember any particular one I
don't but I do remember he did a solo
album that was the expensive Winos right
yeah yeah it was I dig that album
actually he's really really really
talented really cool guy do you think he
was playing those songs for you showing
off and knowing you used to do no you
think it was just like that he was
really curious right there no he was
really curious because he he knew I had
been around you know a lot of people in
the music industry and also I'm Black
and I'm cool right and he knew I had
ears you know I think they can sense
whether you know somebody is cool and
they have ears and whatever and I did I
do have ears it's being called hard in
other words I was never a cool guy I I
don't know how to be cool I don't know
how to be comfortable in a crowd I don't
know how to hang what does it mean yeah
how do you do all that well I think that
you you you don't say very much and and
that's the secret no you have hit it
yeah I talk too [__] much I could
never be cool be like an observer you
know it's almost like Andy Warhol he
never spoke it was so weird and he even
called me up one day and he didn't say
anything he didn't say anything that's
the coolest move I mean really
let me understand something you are very
careful in your career in in um okay in
Sports Illustrated of course you wore
bikinis and stuff like that you were the
only one I think on three covers or
something crazy like that but uh you
were asked by playboy to be uh in
Playboy you did not go naked you
appeared on the cover but you were not
nude you also in uh National Lampoon's
Vacation your character was supposed to
be topless you refused right you stayed
in your bra and panties in that swimming
scene is that it so you have you have
never done nudity am I correct correct
like Cindy Crawford was in here and she
had done nudity like she she did like
you know tasteful nudes yes that was by
Design though you did not want to show
off your assets that way fashion
magazines nothing like that tasteful
news I mean I did I did
um I was nude on the set but with
nothing showing kind of thing right do
you regret that because when you're in
the prime modeling years you would have
had that those pictures forever like you
know
and
you know I was I always my number one
thing in life I knew I wanted to be a
mom I love the idea of a big happy
family you know and and that was my goal
and I thought you know do I want the
kids to have to be there on the
playground with kids going here's your
mom you have none of those issues with
the kids because you you don't have
those pictures floating around yeah and
and you never got into any scandal with
sex videos or anything like that you
avoided all that [__] not yet not yet
but it's just there's still time it's
time